hey what's up guys it's mkbhd here back
with another video now I don't know if
you've noticed but as an Android
follower an avid Android follower for
the past couple of years I've noticed a
trend that's become increasingly more
and more apparent there is a massive
difference between iPhone commercials
and Android commercials I know I know I
don't usually talk about iPhone stuff or
iOS stuff in my videos but if you agree
with me just go ahead and give this
video a thumbs up because there has been
a gigantic gap between the two and I
think that you guys will agree with me
here so let's go ahead and take a quick
look at part of this iPhone ad here for
instance the iPhone 4s has an all-new
camera with 8 megapixels and advanced
optics so it lets you capture stunning
photos so as you can see right from the
beginning of the ad they cut right to
the chase and they immediately show the
phone no ad no no extra stuff no frills
their kit that could only be a
commercial for one thing an iPhone
there's no way that could be a
commercial for anything else from the
first two seconds of the video now let's
go ahead and take a look at this ad for
the Droid Bionic or start off with this
mysterious overview then something Falls
then this girl picks it up and oh she's
just kind of hot and then then this
robot behind her okay she's gonna fight
this thing alright did oh damn looks
like she just yeah she just could his
face off and tickets HDMI cable alright
well uh is this is this Oh a new robot
okay wait a lightsaber do you do work on
that is this it there's a Tron trailer
keep in mind this is from a fairly
tech-savvy person like me I'm guessing
for the average Joe watching that
commercial would go a little something
like this would be it'd be like they'd
press play or they'd watch it on the TV
it would be like this
seriously this is the reason why the
iPhone is the phone for people who
aren't tech savvy or just don't care
about specs or don't really do that much
on their phones this is why the iPhone
is so damn popular in those categories I
haven't seen a single phone commercial
for an Android phone in the United
States that has made me want to buy the
phone if I didn't already want to not a
single one I've never wanted to buy an
iPhone but watching iPhone commercials
honestly makes me think about like what
would happen if I switch to an iPhone I
obviously can't because like other
reasons but seriously why why can't I OS
and Android make similar commercials oh
right they'd get they'd get sued well
here's part of the reason Apple controls
everything that they put into the iPhone
commercials that's just an apple
commercial Apple does everything into
those commercials with the Android stuff
most of those are in Google commercials
I've seen a few Nexus ads but all the
rest of them are Verizon or AT&T or
Sprint ads the Bionic ad we watched is a
Verizon ad and they somehow have to
promote Verizon in the ad to not just
the Bionic and that's why we've seen so
much extra crap thrown in there and
they're not really showing the phone as
much so to sum it all up here's an
iPhone ad and here's an Android ad
pretty clear difference if you guys
agree show this video with your
smartphone enthusiast friends maybe
they'll agree with us and we can try to
get the word out to a Verizon that
they're they're doing it wrong you can
view the full version of each of the as
I showed you guys in the description
below if you're that interested and make
sure you guys like this video and if you
haven't already go ahead and subscribe
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
thanks for watching guys peace
you